this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is joshua fields
milburn ryan nicodemus is on vacation
today so
i'm here with erwin mcmanus and aaron
mcmanus our returning champion and the
new challenger
we're here today now i got to be frank
with you guys um
we had this spot open up today so i
asked you all to come in
we had a porn star who was supposed to
be here today who canceled on us so i
said why not
replace a porn star with a preacher well
there you go and
uh actually we we it was a former porn
star she was going to come in and talk
about
porn addiction and and how a lot of
young men in particular are struggling
with with this sort of addiction so
she'll be back on the podcast to talk
about that but we're here on the
occasion uh you just started a new
season of your podcast you both run a
podcast together
it's called battle ready and if i i
looked it up
aaron talk to me about this because i
looked it up and it said it was a
leadership
podcast but for me i always thought it
was i thought it was a parenting podcast
it's that would be a better description
for the podcast we were talking about
this this week that it's actually not a
leadership podcast
we got a review that said if you're
looking for three steps you won't find
them
so you know we started we started the
podcast a few years ago
after you had written a book called the
last error in the last chapter was
called titled about already you were
battling cancer
and we and i had kind of approached you
and said what if we take this last
chapter and unwrap some of these like
life lessons
questions that i have and things that
maybe we won't be able to ask if
if you don't make it through and we were
kind of in this season where everything
was coming really fast and
so we started the podcast not knowing if
we'd ever get past five episodes and now
it's three seasons in
and really the first two were kind of a
figure fourth season we're
kind of figuring it all out i don't even
know what season we're in yeah at first
we said a uh weekly podcast um
that we will release my review like yeah
so we didn't do one for like six months
yeah and yeah and so we were really not
maybe committed to continuity at that
time
and a lot of it was because um we
weren't really sure
one you know what we wanted to really
address and step into and it's not
i would say it's not a leadership
podcast it's for me it's much more of a
a life cultural podcast it's it's a it's
a place where we get to talk about all
the stuff you're not supposed to talk
about on sunday
and you know and so i you know as you
know i
i started mosaic and i speak on sunday
every week but there are certain things
that
that really you shouldn't talk about in
terms of my opinion shouldn't matter so
much on sunday
what matters on sunday is really how to
help people change how to help people
connect
to their faith how to help people live a
profoundly spiritual life
um and so i never talk about things like
politics or social issues as much and
but we wanted to have a podcast we could
just talk about whatever we wanted
unfiltered
um no no holds bars and just go at it
and have a great time so it's kind of
evolved
well it has and what i what i really
appreciate about the reason that you
started is man i wish i would have had
that my mother died of cancer about a
decade ago
and i man one of my biggest regrets i
spent a lot of time with her that last
year but
i wish i could have you know i would
wish i could have spent more time but in
a way
i wish i could have captured some of
these these wonderful
profound conversations we had together
and you're doing that now
now obviously or when you went through
that that whole battle and so battle
ready
is more than just that that one
particular battle it's like we're all
going through
some sort of battle yeah absolutely and
that was aaron's pitch to me because i
i actually wasn't the one who picked the
title of the podcast he could say no we
need to call it battle ready because
um there are daily battles everybody's
going through and if we could just help
people
face the challenges they have every
single day would be pretty helpful to
people and
and and frankly there are like dynamics
when they had cancer
and not knowing whether i would live not
knowing whether the last there was last
book
or whatever right i found out right
before christmas right before
my wife kim's birthday and right and and
our whole family was going through that
process and
and i realized that so many people are
facing things like cancer and
and face just facing deep like life
struggles and
he didn't have a place to process those
emotions and
and so that's how we began was really
just trying to help people make it
through the day
and and then out of that we just started
having more and more fun
and frankly at first aaron did not want
to talk all he wanted to do was just
set me up to talk he would just ask a
question and and each time we'd finish
and say you have to talk more
he was i don't have anything to say and
i go no you have a lot to say you just
don't know i don't know if you want to
put it out there
and into the public domain right and so
what's happened over time
is that aaron has found his voice and he
argues with me a lot he interrupts me
he's disrespectful
and that's right so now the podcast
really has juice because you don't
really need one person
who just asks other person questions you
need people who challenge your thinking
who
say i disagree with you who who jump out
and go i think you're wrong
and that's been really fun yeah i love i
love the dynamic and uh you brought your
little sister on
the podcast recently too i was just
listening to that episode mariah right
yeah she's awesome she's my little
sister but she acts older
and she's married she's been married her
husband jake is awesome and so
they're both kind of these touring
musicians and they're super talented
and so we we have this interesting
dynamic where you know she just tries to
parent me as well so it really is a
parenting podcast it's all about
how to grow you know i guess battle
ray's really about parenting aaron
well our podcast is very listener driven
so we've got some questions here i
figured we would dive in
to the audience questions claire in
brooklyn has a question for us
i am a writer and often review and cover
beauty products for various publications
i am constantly getting free products in
the mail and at events
i love receiving them but it's stuff i
didn't realize i wanted in my life in
the first place
sometimes when things are free i feel
the urge to hold on to them or the
appetite to acquire them even more
i try to give away stuff to friends but
sometimes with items like these it's a
sanitary concern to share something i've
used
i hate to just throw them in the trash
some of these items cost a lot of money
even if i didn't spend any of my own
money on them a lot of these things are
just in case items
they occasionally give me value but not
always any thoughts
so aaron uh while we were listening to
this you looked up at your dad and you
said uh
that sounds just like you did well i
wanted to talk about this because you're
you're also in a unique position
you get a lot of stuff people want to
give you guys stuff
we've even been told that gift giving is
a love language
i totally disagree with that but i'll
explain why i disagree with that i think
contribution is a love language and
sometimes the best way to contribute to
someone is
via some sort of physical thing but
often
we think it's a shortcut but there are
no shortcuts in fact
this doesn't even seem like a stuff
problem to me this seems like a
commitment problem so so we're saying
yes if we say yes to everything we
say no to the most important things and
so by saying yes i'll take that you can
give me the free thing you can give me
this you can give me that um we keep
saying yes to that but then what are we
actually
saying no to we're saying no to the calm
or serenity of
of of the lack of clutter now you all
you
you work in a space your your building
is stunningly minimalist it's
aggressively
minimalistic and i love it i absolutely
i i think
what you have done is is astonishing and
and so how do you though deal with a lot
of this
how do you say no to some of these
things the first thing i say is clear
nothing is free it
no one sends you anything for free
you're just paying it with a commodity
you're not paying attention to
and if i could maybe just even use an
example with i don't know if you're
allowed to name particular products but
like i've been really huge
on duolingo during the quarantine
learning portuguese
and uh and i found myself after 150
straight days
being addicted to not be able to break
that streak
and so suddenly i'm doing something
that's free and it's actually good for
me and i'm learning portuguese
but i realize oh wow they tricked me
i'm addicted to their affirmation
that little little alarm comes on you
have 150 days streak you know don't lose
it you're indeed
and so what has hap happened this week
is i had to
stop myself and it's so hard
psychologically
and and and so i'm letting it expire so
that i lose my streak so that
i'm in control of what i'm doing
and i think a lot of times it happens
you get free things and you think
they're free but they're not
they're taking something from you you
just have to decide is is what you're
being offered
worth what you have to give up for it
yeah
aaron you deal with getting free things
from time to time and it's enticing
right
not for not for me i throw his free
stuff away all the time
i don't throw it away i give it to
someone else
to be clear it's easy to get rid of
other people's stuff it's easy to get
yeah i'm the guy i buy the same t-shirt
like again and again and again i we talk
about this all the time i'm
cons i learned this from you i i get rid
of so much my closet is iraq if you went
to his
place you would be uncertain if anyone
lived there
because it's so simple after how many
years a decade you finally brought a you
bought a death dresser dresser and it
took them 10 years to decide to buy a
piece of furniture
right i've had a cat the same couch for
the last 12 years i've had you know i
bought a tv because we do a lot of
television stuff but
but yeah no i don't i don't really like
free stuff to me is a burden
i'd rather something be worth buying
because that for me is like actually a
transaction that i take very deeply
free for me is unwanted unless it's like
uh
time like i love and i think time is a
gift like the the gift of time is huge
for me but
but that isn't i don't have to throw it
away later i think what happens is we we
confuse our resources right we we see
money we know that's a resource because
you can hold it in your hand you can
hand it to someone else
i can't hand you my time that's a
precious resource
and there's no refund for time that is
poorly spent
and i think the same is true with our
attention right
our attention is probably our most
precious resource because you can spend
time together but if there's no
attention there then the time isn't
worth
as much right and so i think what's
happening here
is we're we're saying well you know what
claire yeah you're getting some
some free stuff and we all have problems
holding on to things to certain things
sometimes it's stuff sometimes it's
toxic relationships uh sometimes it's
addictions we hold on to a lot of things
and i think the first step to
to to letting go is loosening your grip
and realizing you might have some
boundaries up
as well because for me my boundary is a
pretty strict one i don't accept any
free stuff from corporations or whatever
just because
we're the minimalists and like it would
be a strange thing if i'm like
you know that's why we started out each
podcast with advertisements suck
because it just can you imagine us being
on here
talking about like well and this we're
brought to you by this mattress or
these penis pills or whatever it happens
to be and it's like well wait a minute
like
does doesn't that actually say you
connected the mattress with the pills
i'm sorry go ahead
that's good so um claire you did mention
the just in case adams that's one of the
rules we have we have this rule called
the
the justin case rule it's one of 16
rules that we have in the minimalist
rule book it's a free
e-book that you can download the
minimalists.com
rulebook or if you want the audiobook
version that's now available for
purchase ryan and i record the audiobook
but we did like um
like 16 different mini podcasts with
each different rule that we have
i think that'll help you out a lot let's
move on to our next question from
julianne in portland maine
much of what you talk about with
minimalism
such as not relying on material goods
for commitment of contentment
or living in the present moment without
being reactionary
i strongly identify with as i've grown
up practicing buddhism
and i was wondering if you've ever
written or spoken about the similarities
between
buddhism and minimalism you know it's
fascinating ryan and i have been on nine
tours in the last 10 years we've gotten
book tours or
film tours and people come up to us in
like the hug line afterward which can
you imagine hug lines we used to hug
people you guys remember that
uh and anyway people will come up to us
and they say
hey you know it's so great to see two
guys out here spreading jesus's message
and i'm like hey thanks really
appreciate that next person you know 10
people later next tour stop hey it's
really great to see a couple buddhists
out here
just spreading the good word and then
someone else you know later in
that month will be like hey did you guys
know that muhammad was the original
minimalist
and and and it's like oh cool and so
you know i think what happens is we take
our belief system and then we sort of
map it on to to something else
but but um yes i think a lot of a lot of
religions or you could go even go back
to stoics or whomever
they did talk about as julianne said not
relying on material goods for our
contentment however it doesn't mean that
we're
allergic to material goods either
yeah i think that for me early on in my
life i was very much a monastic
everything i owned i could put into one
paper bag
wow and so one way before it was
um novel uh or uh
something of cultural interest or
intrigue i was i was like this
and so when my wife and i were married i
wouldn't even buy us a bed i slept on
the floor
and i told her that a bed was a luxury
not a necessity
sorry i still that still blows my mind
but keep going so when people talk about
minimalism
i lived at an extreme level of
minimalism for many many years
and i i only worked enough to eat
and which yeah it wasn't it wasn't
always a good ratio some days i didn't
even have
the money to eat i i would wait to wash
clothes and
and until i had enough change to wash
clothes i mean
i was truly minimal and
i moved across the country i got a ride
with someone i didn't have a car
i didn't own anything and he said well i
don't have enough room in my car for you
and i
and i said oh for your luggage i said i
don't have any luggage
and uh moved across the country i had no
place to live no job
no food nothing the clothes i have is
pretty much what i wore and
and but i i but a huge part of me was
i despised the material world
and i don't think i had a healthy
relationship with with creation because
creation nature is a part of the of the
of the
material world and i and i i feel like i
didn't
understand that um enjoying this life
was
not an evil yes i had to come to a place
where
i i wasn't owned by things but but i
could celebrate the beauty of things
and i and i did have to go to an
evolution of that i had to go through
a season i remember when i went to this
pastor that knew me when i was brand new
in my faith because i became a follower
of jesus as an adult
and i said i'm thinking about getting
married and i introduced him to kim and
he told me kim is perfect for you
because she was an orphan
she lived in poverty she was left
starving for several weeks when she was
a child at the age of eight
and that was the negative side of
minimalism yeah and
he said you would never have anything in
your life but because you love her
you're going to
you're going to get things simply to
take care of her wow
and i realize that also there's an
expression of love
that teaches you how to relate to things
and i think in a healthy way
right and i think that's the key it's in
a healthy way because
i grew up really poor uh in dayton ohio
food stamps government assistance
and that wasn't minimalism for me
because it wasn't intentional right
and so what we're talking about now is
is bringing things into our lives
intentionally and and the things that
add value questioning the things i think
that's become the problem with
consumerism there's nothing inherently
wrong with consumption we all need some
stuff
but when it becomes the driver for
everything that we do
we start to to lose sight now aaron how
did this
rub off on you growing up
underneath irwin's reign his tyrannical
reign of not owning things you were you
were
different growing up because i think you
were kind of in this place where you
know
we were definitely wealthy but but you
were but
we always had everything we needed like
always remember having clothes remember
never being really hungry but but i but
also like as i got older and obviously
living in la like you realize okay the
disparity in wealth or the disparity and
like
lifestyle and as we grew and as you
wrote books and as things kind of
you got more successful i realized like
it's super easy to get caught up in like
what car do i drive
where do i live what's the zip code you
know go where do i go out to eat where
do i do this and
i think for us it was a huge
conversation of like what's the life of
that style that you can obtain or can
achieve and live at or where do you
actually feel like you're making the
most
effect in the world and bringing the
most change and actually doing things so
it was less about
how much stuff and then what what are
you doing with the things that you
actually do have
and he you always taught me that it's
always what you have inside of you than
than the things that you can hold with
your hands and so you know
i do drive a good car now but but i but
i drove the same
mini cooper until i wrecked it for for
however long that i
i could and and and they were they're
things that
i grew up without but i also never felt
like i needed
and so to see it now i think it helps me
with my world view of going like i can
be anywhere and
be comfortable i can go to to to
to a place of luxury or a place of of
poverty and go like i feel at home
because it's joy that i
value and it's kindness and it's
sometimes not always kindness working on
being kinder but
but there's these attributes of
characteristics of like a people's
personality i think that i
that i care about more than things i
think that
what's fascinating is you talked about
there's nothing wrong with with pleasure
um and i agree with that as long as it
doesn't get in the way of our actual
contentment or joy right and i think one
of the problems right now is we confuse
pleasure we confuse the dopamine rush
with
everlasting joy or contentment or even
happiness which is also fleeting but i
think is a byproduct of something
healthier than
just pure hedonistic pleasure
right now or when i heard you mention on
a recent episode of
of the battle ready podcast we'll put a
link to the podcast in the show notes
for folks who want to check it out uh
you talked about money versus
freedom and i thought this was
applicable to julianne's question here
where actually do you want to riff on
that a little bit that's interesting
thank you for listening now i know you
actually listen to the podcast
no and yeah i i think a lot of people
um well i i just had knee surgery so
um during the quarantine i had a couple
of accidents when i busted my face open
so i had 15 stitches in my face and
uh and then i uh blew out my knee so i
had to have knee surgery and so i've
been going through physical therapy and
um i have a young guy who's japanese
who's my therapist and as we began
talking he said man i'm just
i'm just driven by things whenever i'm
going through therapy i end up doing
therapy for people i mean
it's always like this and so he he said
i feel like i'm i'm greedy
i just want more and whenever i have
something i want more and i'm never
satisfied and
and so i said as he was trying to help
me you know retrain my knee
uh i said your problem is that you're
more driven by my money than you are by
freedom
and and like i said look i can tell you
i've been extremely poor and i've been
extremely wealthy i
i've had the spectrum of of that human
experience
and um i i feel most content
when i feel that i've attained a freedom
to be who i
who i long to be and to express my life
the way i long to live it
and there there is this odd illusion
that more gives you more freedom
but there's actually a break point where
if you're driven by more you lose all
your freedom
yeah and it's this whole idea of living
for retirement i mean what an
idiotic idea yes right to work all of
your life at a job you hate
so that you can vacate it when you don't
have the energy to live the life you
longed for yeah and and so i i just
think it's a
it's a good measuring point to go uh
well if i were completely free like i've
asked people if you had all the money in
the world
what would you want your life to look
like and they normally say i don't know
and so i said okay here's the problem
you're trying to to get more wealth to
live a life
you don't even know what it looks like
so
so you're actually living an illusion of
what other people tell you
that if you can attain you will finally
be happy
and so you need to in my life i find
incredible joy
when my family is able to uh
you know enjoy each other and love each
other and have time together and
when we're able to have conflict at a
minimal level and and
and everyone's has a sense of meaning
and intention in their life
it isn't measured by money no and and
we've had those moments when we had less
money we've had those moments and we've
had more money
that's why i don't see money as the is
the enemy
of of contentment i think greed is the
enemy of contentment
yeah and uh and i i see money as a
resource just like
if you know the other day um i i
cooked um six whole chickens and uh
and six racks of ribs i took on my
birthday decided to cook all day
and because i thought what would be the
most enjoyable thing during my birthday
and i said
like feeding people like doing working
all day to create a beautiful experience
for people
and i think if we just shift our lives
to like the celebration of me isn't
everybody bringing me something
celebration of me is me bringing
something to everybody
and that's what i i would love for
people to kind of
see that really what you want to do is
you want to be in that that pocket
where um you're actually
to live freely being the person you long
to be
and your resources become a conduit of
all the good you long to do
yes well julianne i hope hope uh we can
send you a copy of
one of irwin's books what book should we
send her
well i think maybe the way the warrior
so cravings maybe yeah okay maybe so
crazy
we'll figure it out well aaron will pick
it out i'm gonna send you one actually
so cravings would be good soul cravings
sean if you could reach out to julianne
send her
a copy of that and we're gonna move on
to our lightning round this is where we
we um try to answer text message so
people text us 937-202-4654
those texts literally go to both ryan's
and my phones so we're a little bit
crazy
um and yeah like this weekend i probably
answered i don't know a thousand texts
and um we just sit down on saturday for
a few hours and
you know send some stuff out um but we
don't get back to everyone we get back
to as many people as we can and
here's the thing we try to answer a few
questions on the podcast now during the
lightning round here's what we try to do
we try to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response
uh we call them minimal maxims we put
them in the show notes so people can
copy and paste our pithy answers on
social media if they'd like
by the way we just really ramble on a
little bit and then we'll try to tweeze
out something pithy so don't worry
there's no
no real pressure eric has a question
here i recently
let go of religion but i don't know what
to cling to
next that's an interesting word there i
don't know what to cling to next was
that maybe the problem
the clinging i think the problem is
religion
maybe just maybe go back to faith okay
let's talk a little bit about that
because
so i i'll give you my pithy answer that
we can unpack it a little bit but
uh progress is measured by our ability
to let go
and i think what happens right now is we
cling to something whatever it is it
could be a religion
whatever we're clinging to there's this
great quote from david foster wallace uh
from infinite jest he said everything
i've ever let go of has call marks on it
well that's not letting go at all that's
just being
dragged until you drop so let's talk
about this faith versus religion thing
i'm fascinated by that
well let me just give my quick response
let's do it
and as long as you're looking for
something to cling to you have not let
go of religion
yeah because religious is an external
construct that gives your life
meaning and leaves you feeling
meaningless
and so i i think that there's something
internal
inside of his struggle that he doesn't
believe
he can become so he has to actually put
on
like i i don't clean i don't turn to
religion
and to give me what i'm searching for
and aaron you talked about different
religion and faith maybe you should pop
in there it's been a huge conversation i
think with our whole lifetime because
i'm
wildly ocd so everything for me was i
mean i was the catholic inside of our
christian family of like repeating the
same prayer every single day
and you grew up roman catholic and so
definitely religiously
ocd and so you helped me kind of
understand going okay
it's okay to be ocd and struggle with
rep repetitive
nature of prayer of doing xyz but
finding a real relationship in faith is
very different i think than
being living by the demands of religion
going like this is your guilt or your
shame is so tied to whether you achieve
or you don't or you do this and you do
that
and you're absolved of your sin versus
this faith going like hey there's a god
who wants to know
you there's something out there the
creative director of the universe
if you want to call it that once that
created you and wants to know you
and that's a different type of
relationship that i don't think
sells to mass media people religion
worked because people
were meant to be controlled by certain
people i think people have that ideology
and so
faith for me is is so much more of a
relationship that
that you understand and you listen and
you learn and you talk and you are in an
engaged relationship but that's what i
got yeah no i
uh one i i think there's something
looking to you to be more quotable
no no i'm not trying to be quotable
right now i'm i was
you're allowed to edit things
[Laughter]
we've got a few pithy things we're good
to go let's just expand on it no
the reason is one i i feel like we
we're whenever we're driven by guilt or
shame
we end up in religion when we're
driven by intention uh and meaning
we're more likely to find something
inherently healthy
and you know so like i don't feel a need
to try to convert anyone and i'm a
pastor
i i have a i have a desire to help
people
live the full life they're created to
live and
and when a person tells me man i've let
go of religion but i'm looking for
something to hold on to
i need some institution outside of me to
fix the world
yeah it's almost childish infantile it
is
and and i'm always saying this because
i'm inherently an anarchist i mean i was
i
that that's who i was growing up that's
i never trust institutions i did not
trust religion i did not trust
governments
what i would i trust is the power of
your internal world to shape and create
the world around you
and you if if you're filled with anger
or greed or violence or
envy you're going to create a
destructive world
if you're filled with hope and love
and intention and purpose you're going
to create a better world and
and so i would say look i i don't know
who you are and where you are on your
life journey
but um one i do believe in god and
obviously i am a person who believes in
a personal relationship with jesus
but what i'd say to you is um look for
the change
within you and move toward whatever
moves you toward love move toward
whatever moves you toward hope
like the the best internal compass is
when
all the right essentials begin to be
created inside of you
like i would not be a follower of jesus
if somehow it moved me away from love
if it moved me away from hope if it
moved me away from compassion
like i think that we all have this
internal compass and if we pay attention
to it
it'll move us in the right direction
i get i'm used to this my mind's blown
and my insides are so
inspired right now the the the love
thing is fascinating because i also find
some value
in whether it's religion or whatever
there's this sort of liturgical nature
of religion where people
find some sort of structure right and i
think that's what he's looking
for right now specifically and what
you're saying is that whatever that
structure ends up being
it needs to be predicated on love not on
a set of
particular rituals that are going to
drive you toward love necessarily and
it's just like with injury i've had a
lot of injuries in my life because i
love
playing sports and at first i mean when
i came out the knee surgery they gave me
this massive metal brace
to put on my knee and these really cool
crutches and
and uh i walked out of the hospital i
took the brace off and i put the
crutches down and i started walking
this within the same hour of having the
surgery
and and and my family's like why do you
do this
because the brace is there to protect
you from
injury but it actually also reduces
your capacity to be str stronger
and religion is a brace uh
love is the strength all right before we
get into our listener tips and our added
value segment today it looks like we got
a bunch more surprise questions
this week like why are christians
simultaneously the nicest and meanest
people on earth
how do you find a supportive community
if you're not religious
i'm deeply unsatisfied with my life i
haven't found my passion
and i don't know where to start help
plus
we're gonna talk about dealing with a
dying loved one we're talking about what
kovid has stolen from us over the last
six months
we're talking about church for atheists
we're talking about a million more
questions for
irwin and aaron mcmanus and if you want
to hear all that
subscribe to our maximal episodes on the
minimalist
private podcast it's a completely
separate podcast it's just two bucks
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements by
the way if you're not a private podcast
supporter you're literally missing
two-thirds of our show
i mean seriously it's less than what you
spend on coffee today
probably but there's this whole other
world where we're able to let our hair
down we dive deeper
into topics but we do it in front of a
smaller
private audience and it gives us the
space we need to have some
uncomfortable or difficult conversations
that we typically would not have
in public head on over to
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal links so that our private
podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app seriously
head on over there it keeps this podcast
100
advertisement free thank you to our
patreon supporters it is because of you
we don't have to talk about mattresses
or
um hair replacement or what are the
what else we got podcast sean what's
popular on podcast right now
i don't know i don't want to talk about
any of the advertisements they're all
you know what i end up doing i try to
fast forward through them and then i
mess up and it's just it interrupts the
whole experience so
i'm going to stop interrupting this
experience and let you check out some
voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners hi my name is aubry
from lehigh utah and i was just
calling to say that something that is
difficult for me
is to get rid of items that people give
me as gifts
but something that i have learned is
asking the question
has this served its purpose or has it
helped me feel
the love that that person has for me if
the answer is yes then it serves purpose
and i feel confident that i can get rid
of it
hi this is generally from salt lake i
was calling in regard to
the episodes about relationships and
um the i guess content the
comment that i wanted to make is um both
i think as a single person
and as you're looking for a relationship
when you are
content with who you are before you go
into a wanting a new job or stay
dancing in a relationship um i think
that is where
you build a better relationship than you
could if you were looking for someone
else to
fulfill that or if you were looking for
fulfillment through
a job or doing you know the next object
a um and the thing that i have found in
my life that makes me content or makes
me at least
aware of what i need to change in order
to be content
is gratitude if i am grateful for the
things that i have in my life even the
negative things
um that teach me patience or that teach
me compassion or that teach me
um to be frugal then
i am content uh i may want to change
but i am content with who i am in that
moment and i think that has
for me has been the essential point of
being a happy person
um is to be grateful for the needs that
i have
all right y'all thanks again to irwin
and aaron mcmanus for joining us today
check out their podcast it's called
battle ready we'll put a link to that in
the show notes but you can listen to it
wherever you listen to podcasts or check
out the video version it is
really beautiful let's put a link to
their youtube channel mosaics youtube
channel
in the show notes as well you can find
aaron and
irwin both on instagram as well
for added value this week sean don't get
mad at me but i think we're going to
play a song at the end of this one
it is called brave by ruston kelly from
his new album
shape and destroy now i've i recommended
his last album when it came out a few
years ago on the podcast
and i think this is the one added value
i've gotten more compliments for over
the years
compared to anything else that i've
recommended that that
original album of his i think was his
first album called dying star
it's a masterpiece now he's followed up
with this new album
shape and destroy and this song the
whole the whole album is great but this
song is particularly special
it is called brave and you're going to
hear that at the end of this episode
but real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of
the minimalists we just launched our new
minimalist rule book it's i talked about
it earlier in the episode but it's 16
rules for living with less that ebook
was
it came out earlier this year so many
people have found value in it
but if you prefer to listen as opposed
to read you can read it for free by the
way
the minimalists.com rulebook but if you
prefer to listen you can now purchase
the audiobook
version it's 18 different tracks there's
an intro and a conclusion but then the
16 rules in the middle
but with each one of those rules ryan
and i we came into the studio
we did a mini podcast for each
rule and we really invented some new
rules along the way
as well it's one of my favorite things
that we've ever done and now that it's
in this audio book form
you can sort of go through the rules one
by one you can even follow along by
printing out
the free e-book or you can read the
e-book on whatever device
you want but i would encourage you to
check out the audio book
because it's a deeper dive it shows you
how ryan and i apply these rules to our
own life whether it's the 2020 rule or
the 30 30 rule or the 90 90 rule
or the emergency item rule how do we
apply all 16 rules to our own lives how
have we seen them work for other people
as well and then we expand on those by
inventing several new rules along the
way
the minimalists.com rulebook if you want
to check that out download the free
e-book version
or you can also get the audiobook
version which is now available
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalists
come to one of our live podcast shows
when you can visit the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast
email voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com
the minimalist we also have a new
podcast channel youtube.com
the minimalist podcast we separated our
channels there go ahead and head on over
to
that new channel give us a starter
comment a starter like
to get us up in the algorithms to help
our simple living message
reach more ears and if you want our show
notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at theminimalists.com
you'll also receive our simple sunday
emails whenever we send those
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it